well you're hearing demands all of a
sudden mostly from Democrats but also
from some Republicans for new gun
control measures some like beta a worker
demanding outright gun confiscation but
not everyone on the left is on board
Jason Nichols is professor of
african-american studies the University
of Maryland and he joins us named
professor thanks lot for coming on so we
don't agree on much I think you're a man
of good faith I love having you on the
show but we sincerely disagree I would
say on most issues absolutely but in
talking off the air the other day you
said something really interesting to me
and I wanted you to explain it more
fully for our audience that you're not
reflexively on board with gun control
measures so there there are some
common-sense gun control measures that I
think makes sense even limiting the
capacity of a magazine we saw for
example in Gilroy California where a guy
had a 75 round drum connected to his
weapon I'm against that I don't think we
need silencers I think we need universal
background checks but gun confiscation
goes way too far when we look at the
history of gun control in this country
it has been to keep guns out of the
hands of black people and that's
indisputable fact I would point anybody
to Adam Winkler's work out of UCLA as a
matter of fact when you go back to the
antebellum period it was to keep guns
out of the hands of both enslaved and
free African people and then you go to
Roger Taney who wrote the infamous Dred
Scott yes and one of the things that he
said was that he didn't think that black
people had rights that white people were
bound to respect in part because he
thought if you extended those rights
that they would have the rights to carry
and own guns the Ku Klux Klan the the
infamous terrorist group conservative
terrorist group that regardless of party
but at the same time that group were
advocates of gun control so I think
honestly you know when you look at the
history of the issue I think that you
know African American people should be a
little leery about people wanting to
come around and take their gun yeah
yes I'm sorry to laugh but you make it
you make a compelling case because what
you're saying is factually true and this
is a non-racial point it should be point
about human nature but when you want to
oppress somebody you disarm them first
of course and you've seen that in
totally homogeneous countries where race
is not a factor but the first thing the
government does is disarm the population
before doing something horrible to them
obviously so because what you just said
is so clearly true why is it so rarely
said out loud you know I'm not exactly
sure you know some of our civil rights
heroes that are oftentimes not
acknowledged whether we're talking about
the Deacons for defense or we're talking
about Robert F Williams I'm not sure
exactly why people don't state this that
was marking for gun control well dr.
King at one point was certainly a gun
owner and at one point they actually
said a journalist nearly sat on top of a
gun in his home and called his home in
Arsenal so many of the king's home on
our smart luther king but at the same
time there are organizations that have
worked against black people that are
pro-gun and they're pro-gun control when
it comes to black people like the NRA so
that has a well I would I would say I'm
not here to speak for the NRA but as
someone who believes in the Second
Amendment I believe it's a universal
principle that applies it goes without
saying but I will say it explicitly that
applies without regard to race of course
it applies to all human beings it's a
god-given right the right to
self-defense and I think most people of
good will believe that how much crap
will you take for saying something so
obvious on this I take crap every time
I'm on this show from one side of the
other so you know I think I'm prepared
for the crowd for it professor thank you
very much for coming on I hope that
people can rise above the partisanship
just for a second and meditate on what
you said because I think it's absolutely
true great to see you thanks a lot